[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
euh bonjour Docteur bonjour Qu'est-ce
qui ne V pas j'ai des frissons dans
l'estomac oui j'éclate de rire quand il
faut pas je fais des claquettes à
l'Opéra je dans Bou sur le pont de l'AL
vous claquez du doigt oui oui vous tapez
du pied oui
[Musique]
oui vousê swing
swingtwingwingwingwingoursours monsieur
auin de la
[Musique]
rueantoui
lui rondelle c'est un grand swing un
super craque et quand il est là il faut
que ça claque Swing Swing vachement
swing complètement ch
[Musique]
swingazwingwingwing swing ah bonjour
monsieur le curé je voudrais bien me
confesser car j'ai acquis la salle
pratique de chanter en chous les ah mon
cétait formidable cette musique est très
valable CR n Jésus Jésus Jésus Swing
Swing
jésusachementwing SaintEsprit ch
[Musique]
swing
Swing Swing complètement
[Musique]
chwing Charles
bois